jean philippe bloch professeur
spécialisé en économie urbaine c'est à
l'école d'urbanisme et d'architecturé à
l'université de montréal bonsoir je
manage bonjour est ce que il y à des
leviers que peu utilisé le gouvernement
du québec pour apaiser la crise mais
d'abord je vous pose la question est-ce
que vous comme spécialistes vous
considérer qu'il ya une crise du
logement
c'est certain que le rapport entre les
revenus d'aider des gens et ils le coût
des loyers ou des maisons à l'heure
actuelle à montréal j'avais été aussi
élevé donc est ce que ça veut dire que
c'est un être crise c'est sûr que le
marché dans son chauffe
après quand on compare montréal avec des
marchés comme ceux toronto ou vancouver
on s'aperçoit qu'on on est encore loin
des situations qui sont véhicules à bord
donc je pourrais pas vous dire et l'est
où la ligne
on commence à appeler sur une crise ou
pas crise mais c'est certain que la
situation jamais été aussi troublante
que celle qu'on prenait présentement à
montréal
ok mais c'est important vous dites y'a
pas contrairement à la récession à d il
n'y a pas une des critères objectifs qui
font qu'on aperçoit une crise du
logement
à ma connaissance il y en a peut-être
qui en a qui en ont déjà déterminé mais
disons qu'il ya des marchés qui sont
complètement hors prix
traditionnellement par exemple vancouver
et là l'endroit canado ça coûte le plus
cher c'est logique ça ç'a toujours été
comme ça
ce qu'on remarque qui tendance qui
change un peu c'est que le une
accélération du phénomène
aucune des connexions de plus en plus
grande entre le revenu des ménages et le
coût des logements mais comme je vous
dis si on fait le ratio des revenus sur
les sur les coûts du logement à montréal
on est à peu près le prix d'une maison
moyenne sur un revenu moyen n'est pas
peine 1 et celle de 5,6 à vancouver son
échelle de 10 donc on s'entend que c'est
presque deux fois plus cher qu'à
montréal et donc ça nous donne une
perspective sur qu'est-ce qui pourrait
venir dans le futur on est capable de
voir pire que nous qu'est ce qui
explique la hausse si rapide des loyers
dans une ville comme montréal mais pas
que
là on le disait à québec à sherbrooke
ailleurs il ya un phénomène qui est
canadien qui met aussi dans la plupart
des grandes villes du monde à l'heure
actuelle on doit on à ces phénomènes
l'aude hausse du coût des logements donc
un phénomène je dirais qui tient
l'économie en général d'oki tient
l'économie canadienne il faut comprendre
que le canada est un des pays dans le
monde qui reçoit le plus d'immigrants
par rapport à sa population
mais ça c'est quelque chose que toujours
existé ou existent depuis plusieurs
années mais des fois le flou s'accélère
plus vite qu'on l'anticipé est en fait
le prix des logements est tributaire de
juste de la pointe de l'iceberg c'est à
dire que c'est le nombre de nouveaux
ménages qui se crée le nombre de
nouveaux logements qu'on est capable de
générer à chaque année si on n'a pas une
bonne adéquation entre ces deux choses
là il génère un phénomène de rareté et
là c'est ce qui se produit à l'heure
actuelle c'est à dire que le nombre de
nouveaux ménages qu'on a au canada soit
discret de l'intérieur soit qu'ils
viennent parfaire l'extérieur ce nombre
là s'accroît plus rapidement que notre
capacité à construire des logements pour
combler la demande
hélas les taux d'inoccupation fondre
puis après ça il ya surenchère sur ce
qui reste de disponible alors devant
cette situation là que vous expliquez
bien qu est ce que le gouvernement du
québec pour prendre l'exemple du québec
pour faire pour frais mais c'est ce que
jodie levier vraiment qui serait
efficace pour comprendre que le marché
immobilier c'est un marché qui
fonctionne réel en main c'est pas comme
quand on a une crise de consommation là
comme on en a eu au début de la colline
le gouvernement canadien aux jeux sans
imprimer de l'argent et envoyé des
chèques ça s'est fait pendant quelques
semaines
c'est une réaction très rapide au niveau
du logement sim en quarante mille
logements comprenez que le gouvernement
peut pas imprimer 40 ni logement qui
renvoyait sa pizza mais on va vous
installer là dedans
donc c'est un marché qui fonctionne très
lentement les problèmes on les voyait
venir mais même si on les voit venir a
pendant plusieurs années le temps que ça
juste et c'est très lent les promoteurs
immobiliers veulent pas nécessairement
prendre trop de risques donc il essaie
d'anticiper de manière conservatrice les
hausses de demande est là plusieurs
années de suite on s'est vraiment trop
pédant dans combien de logements il
fallait s'y ne met pas en marche et
poursuivent leur est donc on a pris du
retard dans la production et ce retard
le cumulatif doit être résorbé
mais même si on essaie d'agir maintenant
aujourd'hui pour lancer des logements
sur le marché ça peut prendre plusieurs
années avant que ça se résorbe et
peut-être que la demande va avoir
descendu un peu d'ici là donc l'essence
des gouvernements les leviers sont pas
nombreux c'est ça vous n'êtes pas si
simple que ça intervenir l'idée on se
quitte là dessus j'en fais les palaces
l'idée de geler que ça se fait l'idée de
geler les loyers dire pour une année on
gèle ce que ça peut se faire dans un
marché comme celui là à court terme ça
peut aider les gens qui paye un loyer le
problème c'est qu'à long terme ça peut
déséquilibrer le marché puis exacerber
le problème c'est que depuis très
longtemps on n'investit plus dans les
logements locatifs au québec parce que
les hausses de loyers sont trop lente
par rapport au prix du marché donc les
gens préfèrent construire des propriétés
voilà qui vont être vendus pour des
propriétaires et si on met encore plus
de contraintes dans le marché en gelant
les loyers mais on va faire fuir encore
plus les investisseurs éventuellement on
va voir encore moins où on veut
convoquer jugement encore plus lentement
et l'eau à long terme on risque de se
retrouver avec un problème qui va être
exacerbée comme une fausse bonne idée
dit vous donc c'est intéressant vous dit
on les constructeurs font des condos au
fond des choses qui se vendent bien pour
les gens qui veulent acheter mais des
immeubles à logements compte tenu que
pendant des années les loyers des baux
considérer bon ici c'est pas intéressant
économiquement pour se retrouve avec un
manque de ces immeubles sommes en fait
ça fait à peu près 30 ans au québec on
en construit plus est à peu près aussi
simple que ça on en fait pour du
logement social logement abordable où on
en fait pour des résidences pour
personnes âgées mais du logement locatif
qui s'adresse
la classe moyenne par exemple ou aux
gens qui travaillent
il y en a pas vraiment on n'en produit
plus on fabrique du condo enfin un vrai
appartement qu'on entende on fabrique
des propriétés mais on fabrique plus de
logements locatifs parce que en fait il
ya eu un creux dans les années 90 on
construisait plus rien et au tournant
des années 2000 les prises sont mis à
monter mais comme les prix dans les
propriétés monter plus vite que les
loyers baissent et est toujours plus
intéressant
construite du congo et de la propriété
et ça ça pas changé aujourd'hui la seule
embellie convoi dans la production de
logements locatifs présentement c'est le
logement locatif avec service qui
s'adresse aux personnes âgées parce que
on peut récupérer ce qu'on n'a pas dans
loyers dans la vente de services qu'on
va attacher à ces types de résidences
l'a vraiment intéressant je pense qu'on
vienne quand on a compris pas mal plus
de show jean-philippe meloche professeur
spécialisé en économie urbaine à l'école
de d'urbanisme anniversaire de montréal
merci de nous avoir parlé au plaisir